judge katanji jackson has officially
been confirmed to the supreme court
president biden is pleased probably
because jackson's confirmation is the
first political win of his entire
administration but even so
biden is angry that the confirmation
didn't go even easier i knew it wouldn't
be easy
but i knew the person i nominated will
be put through a painful and difficult
confirmation process
but i have to tell you
what judge jackson was put through
was well beyond that
there was verbal abuse the anger
the constant interruptions
the most vile baseless assertions and
accusations
in the face of it all
judge jackson showed the incredible
character and integrity she possesses
the most vile baseless assertions and
accusations
the most vile faceless assertions and
accusations does joe biden not remember
four years ago well actually probably he
does not remember four years ago but
does everyone else not remember four
years ago when during brett kavanaugh's
confirmation hearings the democrats
accused him a squeaky clean milktoast
federal judge
of attempted rape
i believed he was going to rape me
i tried to yell for help
when i did brett put his hand over my
mouth to stop me from yelling
this is what terrified me the most and
has had the most lasting impact on my
life
it was hard for me to breathe
and i thought that brett was
accidentally going to kill me
dr ford
with what degree of certainty do you
believe brett kavanaugh assaulted you
100
what is the strongest memory you have
indelible in the hippocampus is the
laughter
the la the uproarious laughter between
the two
and they're
having fun
at my expense was there ever a time when
you drank so much that you couldn't
remember what happened or part of what
happened the night before i
no in your yearbook
you talked about
drinking
and sexual exploits did you not
indelible in the hippocampus
is the laughter that i engaged in at
this preposterous circus there was no
evidence for any of these claims
none whatsoever that woman christine
ford changed almost all of the crucial
details of her story multiple times she
was caught in multiple lies the other
people said to have been at this party
from hell at the time said they had no
idea what this woman was talking about
even ford's best friend also said to
have been there contradicted ford's
story but that didn't stop democrats
from continuing to smear brett kavanaugh
without any evidence as a rapist and
then even going further to accuse him of
gang rape
a third woman is now leveling damaging
accusations against supreme court
nominee brett kavanaugh her name is
julie swetnick and she's represented by
attorney michael avenatti of stormy
daniels fame swetnick claims that
kavanaugh was present while she herself
was being gang-raped at a house party in
the 1980s
the detail
includes and what is included in
kavanaugh's sworn affidavit excuse me in
avenetti's sworn affidavit that julie
swetnick gave
in it she says in approximately 1982 i
became the victim of one of these gang
or train rapes where michael judge mark
judge and brett kavanaugh were present
shortly after the incident i shared what
had transpired with at least two other
people during the incident i was
incapacitated without my consent unable
to fight off the boys raping me i
believe i was drugged using quaaludes or
something similar placed in what i was
drinking she also says quote i also
witnessed efforts by mark judge brett
kavanaugh and others to cause girls to
become inebriated and disoriented so
they could then be gang raped
gang raped they said that brett
kavanaugh was a gang rapist now this
woman julie swetnick was discredited
almost immediately even the democrats
quickly moved on from her nonsense her
felon lawyer who was previously best
known for defrauding a porn star is
currently in prison for extortion and
wire fraud but to this day to this day
democrats continue to smear brett
kavanaugh as some sort of rapist with
these vague accusations based on
absolutely nothing this after the
democrats led by joe biden baselessly
smeared clarence thomas as a sexual
predator that after the democrats again
led by joe biden because he's been in
politics for that long inaugurated this
whole era of supreme court confirmation
smears during the nomination of robert
bork it created a new verb borking which
is when you smear a candidate for the
court now
joe biden has the audacity to complain
about vile baseless accusations against
catan g jackson
which consisted entirely
of quoting her own record and asking her
basic questions about the world
and i'll confess judge jackson as look
as i listen to your testimony i believe
you are someone who is compassionate i
believe you care for children obviously
your children and other children
but i also see a record
of activism and advocacy as it concerns
sexual predators
that stems back decades and that is
concerning he said to him this is a
truly difficult situation
i appreciate that your family's in the
audience i feel so sorry for them
and for you
and for the anguish this has caused all
of you
i feel terrible about the collateral
consequences of this
conviction
and then you're going to say sex
offenders are truly shunned in our
society
i'm just trying to figure out judge
is he the victim here or the victim's
the victims
you've spoken a lot today about criminal
sentencing about the theory of
sentencing you've written about a lot
about your record it is a very simple
question
is someone more likely or less likely to
commit crime if they're certain more
certain that they're going to be caught
convicted and sentenced
can you provide a definition for the
word woman
can i provide a definition no yeah
i can't
you can't
you can't
you can't the entire process was just
quoting her own record almost entirely
in her own words quoting her own
sentencing record and then asking simple
questions like what is a woman and this
woman maybe she's a woman maybe she's
not i don't know either way she couldn't
answer the only vile and baseless
accusations in the entire jackson
confirmation process have been the ones
that biden and the democrats have hurled
against the republicans about the
process in other words business as usual
i'm glad you like that clip now
ring the bell subscribe make sure you
get the notifications also head on over
to apple podcast spotify stitch or
google play wherever you get your audio
podcasts subscribe to the michael
knowles show leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you